KENDALL ROY:
I'm better than you.
You're corrupt. Evil.
LOGAN ROY: Don't talk about
things you don't understand.
I know things about the world,
or I wouldn't turn a buck.
Fuck off, kiddo.
Hey, I hear you tried
to kill Dad again, Fatty.
Do you have a fetish
for nearly killing Dad?
Like "just the tip,"
but for killing Dad?
♪ DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
Huh. There he is. The little man
who started this big war.
You dragged our reputation
through the mud.
You're acting out a personal
grudge against Dad.
There is a foundational
sickness within our father
and his company.
Or do you not actually give
a fuck, and it's all just ego?
It's war.
I'm gonna jam a Montblanc
down his fuckin' throat.
This is a PR disaster.
They could subpoena you
to the grand jury.
Everybody cooperates.
(CHANTING)
TOM WAMBSGANS: Logan is very
interested in what you're up to.
You better crawl into
a criminal's corpse and hide.
(GULPS, CLEARS THROAT)
Strong. Wow. Nice and strong--
Strong one. Strong for a man.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
KENDALL: I'm takin' my dad down,
and I'm not interested
in any deals with him.
You work for the shareholders,
and I don't bet on blood feuds.
LOGAN:
I need to know where everyone is
and what everyone's thinking.
ROMAN ROY:
We're about to lose the company
at the shareholder meet
'cause you tried
to assassinate our dad.
Roman, stick with me. I'm an
incredibly dangerous enemy.
Oh, don't threaten me, Gerri.
I don't have time to jerk off.
The FBI is downstairs.
Tell 'em to fuck off!
Yeah, these are the ones
who don't fuck off.
Can we ask 'em
to come back tomorrow?
-Logan--
-Are you--
♪ (MUSIC INTENSIFIES) ♪
There are a million knives
being sharpened right now.
He's fuckin' terrified, Shiv.
What is the worst thing
that could be in those papers?
SPEAKER: He doesn't know
what's coming for him.
Your spoon wasn't
shiny enough, huh?
You come for me. What have
you got in your fuckin' hand?
You have no leverage.
I'm in control here.
Listen to me very carefully.
This is you throwing it away.
-Everything I have fought
and bled for.
-Okay...
-I am not gonna let that happen!
Do you understand me?!
-Not fucking--!